it is III 2017 and I'm here in the war
room with Martin who brought by a game
called River bond what's the premise of
this game and it looks like you are
spinning yes what is just fun I can /
you can play on your own or with couch
co-op friends it's a no split screen
it's one screen everybody can play on
the same screen a bit like L diver or
Diablo you can change your skin with
left and right on the d-pad so we're
gonna ship the game with many different
type of skin and also the the point of
it is what we're gonna pay today is the
arcade mode so it's like a little raid
or mission that you can do and over
about ten minutes and there's leather
board you can compete for score and it's
drop and drop out so you can easily play
with with friends without worrying about
winning for people so let's say I have
to do something I can easily just leave
the game and come back and I'm gonna
keep my score and equipment cool so
where we headed so here is just so to
get familiar with the control we have
like the part - with the right bumper
the right trigger is for this word that
you can aim with the right stick and
shoot a shield shield yes you can dodge
roll and here it is some TNT most of the
environment can be destroyed and you can
troll things around send for the chicken
if you start an enemy and they have
little star above the head you can grab
them and throw them in the hole so I
wanted to try to also get this feeling
when you're playing with LEGOs and you
can just wreak havoc on everything and
even if it's this nice guy little plot
of land we're supposed who is supposed
to be the good guy but it doesn't seems
to mind it so here's a start of the
adventure nice port also we entered the
land of the pigs so that evil pigs took
over
and we have to remove them because this
used to be the land of the rabbits shot
him in the hole and we had the game here
at e3 put people playing and some people
were just like spending a lot of time
just cutting the grass but it keep
growing back so you can just go and keep
cutting the grass forever and we're
gonna have eventually random drops
coming for cutting the grass because
people enjoying it too much so maybe
some gems or extra coins it is
satisfying just be able to basically
destroy everything in front of you if
you want to yes and it's part of the fun
even if it doesn't necessarily advance
your mission forward this kind of a fun
to destroying just an environment like
this and we took every opportunity we
had to put a lot of those things in the
game all here's the gate to the cave
entrance so yeah we gotta find a key so
there's a minibus that still it have
blue pig and is hiding in the windmill
so in what am i right now
Oh Europe you're a happy coin and I'm
kind of a texture tiny thing but I could
also be a doughnut when I'm being killed
so in the window full game releases were
you have to switch your character on the
fly or will you pick and then oh you can
you can switch on the fly so we're not
sure yet to lock certainly hit bacon and
bacon in Donuts perfect combo maybe we
can have some some special skin that are
gonna be lock like I don't know we still
open to ideas we have more than a dozen
already but people said I want to play
as a cupcake and some people I all want
to play it's a DVD player or a cup of
coffee so we're gonna have all those
silly icon and also more serious one
like probably em stirs
and eventually also if you beat a level
then you could use the skin of the
enemies so you could play as this little
blue pig it's pretty cool and in terms
of weapons we are having out a starting
weapon which is a swerd in the shield
and and the gun but we're gonna have
much more weapons that we're gonna find
out along the journey we're gonna be
able to spend the coin to buy them we're
gonna be able to level them up some of
the weapons are gonna be a mix of like
fantasy and scifi so we were like okay
this kind of looked like a fantasy game
but we could have a rocket launcher so
okay we don't care we're gonna put
rocket launcher fire bombs mini nukes
and octa on top of that of course we're
gonna have our sights were like in Final
Fantasy or a Dark Soul evil cloud
looking with spikes candy cane so
anything can grab and just smash people
with and you said this I mean this is
meant for four players right now it's a
little bit tougher at the moment yes
because it's been calibrated for player
for each three but we're gonna have an
auto scaling so depending on number
number of player then the difficulty is
gonna be adjusting automatically and
also this is in the full story mode if
you join in a couple of hours and people
are going to be able to level up adjust
their the level of difficulty by
grabbing weapons because it's mostly
equipment base for progression not
necessarily for experience point so if
you can enemy and it drops a huge weapon
and you gain those ability automatically
so if you're playing with somebody who's
very advanced with big weapons you just
gotta kill a bunch of enemies get some
drop give them to you and then you were
at their level more or less because one
thing is the base weapon but you're also
gonna be able to use a skill stone to
infuse your weapon and we don't want it
to avoid too much grinding so if you
find all stone
then you won't lose them if you drop a
weapon they're gonna they're gonna
transfer automatically to your new
weapon do I encourage people to try
different weapons without really any
penalties so if you you find like a
double yielding like dagger then you
could take it replace it from from your
Jewish word and if you don't like it and
grab it back and your other point you
spent on your weapon is gonna be
transferred I'm getting my butt kicked
yes there's a lot of pigs here and it
was the beginning of the game eventually
you have like dozens and dozens of
enemies filling out the screen but of
course any bigger weapon to get rid of
them so it's something we're alike in
Diablo when you reach the later levels
and you have all these armies of people
attacking you and everything just
explode and get destroyed so we're gonna
have a lot of this feeling so it's a mix
of bit of Diablo gauntlet and a good old
arcade fun like a golden axe and Double
Dragon yeah I definitely see the
inspirations and style from the last two
pigs they want to know nice so now we
can open the cave so this is the
underground cave which lead to the final
boss which is the rabbit to change side
and allied with the pig and stole a huge
tank to destroy all the villagers farm
and is when they get the game start this
is just the first five level we have
over 150 levels in the in the whole game
so plenty of adventures different worlds
like we have snow dungeons Castle
deserts swamp all a bit that the classic
one you have like in the arcade or RPG
yeah and all destructible with different
things temples they like there's a huge
temples that if you break the columns
everything falls we have secret area
like this one here you can see the walls
a bit different yeah so we can destroy
it and certain type of wall if they're
made of rock then you need a special
type of bomb to open the secret areas
sometime you need to go to the shop get
this bomb go back to the level and then
you're gonna have a special weapons or
other bonus in the secret area so we
wanted people to be able to not only do
the domain like obvious path but also
explore a bit and find an audit
so like in this area here is not a
distributable wall we have point for now
but in the final version is a chess
would give you more weapons it's where
you're gonna be able to get some of some
weapons for the bus fight coming up cool
so we're still about a couple of months
maybe six eight months until we're we're
finished so probably September October
but from there we're gonna go like
intense testing close better
localization reporting and probably
looking I mean nothing has official
confirm yet but or our aim will be
hopefully to release sometime early 2018
here ah oh my god
one day one is dead is a bit like in
destiny is like cards and down Last
Guardian so you have to stay alive until
you don't want to respond otherwise you
get wiped on so the beginning of the
level oh I'm dead oh oh yes I'm back
that was really cool I like the right
bumper yes and it also this is one of
the first special that we can equip
later special will be like a giant donut
just mashing up and down everything
Thunder that it's gonna be like this
crazy storm pulling up the screen with a
lot of electricity and chains so this
one is very fun but also as you go later
on you're gonna have more and more power
so the idea is that toward the end of
the game when you're fully equipped
everything you look at it and the screen
is just is kind of almost like Alice
nation of colors and explosion
okay so here's the bus fight so those
are it like the guardian of the bus so
if we go a bit further down is gonna
trigger the bus so maybe we want to stay
around these guys
yeah duals guys first there's also some
bombs on the side we can use
and like we see her this shield it's not
effective to block door blow and even if
the game at first is very easy to pick
up and and play
there's a lot of depth in the way the
weapons are gonna be interacting with
the enemies in the environment not only
in terms of being able to block a blow
but also a mental damage if it's fire
it's magic if its eyes and we got a lot
inspired by Dark Soul door weapon system
is so incredible like if you have an axe
is gonna be much more effective against
enemies or organic and made of flesh
then the power armor then you need to
use a blunt weapon so we're gonna have
this depth in the gameplay for the
weapons
seems like we're doing doing all right
you do yes hahaha I played this so many
times and even then I feel like this bus
could be a bit more difficult like
having waves of enemies yeah if you get
stuck in the front and you shoot at you
it's done you a bit and you can get just
hit like in a row so that the trick is a
bit to circle it and try to not to get
too close because they have this kind of
truck if you get too close get
and we're gonna have anything and this
is the first boss we have many busts in
the game there's the Yeti there's a
knife there's some water one that come
out from holes and intro weird stuff and
squid at you and also the environment is
intractable in some level like you have
levers switch trampoline and you can't
roll stuff on trampoline and everything
started bouncing around so not only
cutting the grass but it's a lot of
other stuff that it's a lot of fun too
I've died so many times just by walking
and do hey yes I know it's because it
feels like I'm gonna I'm gonna get you
but if you get too close he is it's easy
because you just turn around so fast and
incidentally you're you're caught in the
fire but almost have him yes nice so
that's enough the demo we're showing it
at e3 but if you look up here like this
gate and the full game is opening up
there's a loot room a bunch of crates
and a reward you can go to the shop
spend your money and then you keep going
to the next level thank who that was
that was River bomb thank you so much
for stopping by
yeah my pleasure anything else you'd
like to add before we wrap this up yes
if you want to follow us on cocoa
cucumber or look for River bond online
we're gonna have more news new trailers
coming out later this year and we're
hoping to come on the console and xbox
early next year
cool thank you so much thank you for
more III coverage make sure to stay
tuned to games but thanks for watching